[Music]
good evening welcome to washington i'm
mike emanuel in for bret baer breaking
tonight we're covering a number of big
stories the death rate is rising at the
site of the collapsed condo towers in
south florida
much of that state is also bracing for
what could be damaging rain and winds
from
tropical storm possibly hurricane elsa
president biden is urging americans who
have not been vaccinated to take the
shot
and says the delta variant of the
coronavirus may be more dangerous
than the original but we begin tonight
with america's crime
crisis a bloody fourth of july weekend
ended with at least
267 people killed in shooting incidents
in chicago 18 people were killed in
shootings involving at least 100 people
police say in nearly all the incidents
no suspects were taken into custody
in cleveland 11 people were shot in a
five hour period
eight people were killed in philadelphia
with 27 others hurt
denver police reported five separate
shootings within a four hour period
in new york embattled governor andrew
cuomo is taking a drastic step due to
the growing gun violence
correspondent brian yennis reports
tonight from times square good evening
brian mike good evening tonight new york
is in a state of emergency the state
will now treat surging gun violence
as a public health crisis the governor
noting today
that over the july 4 weekend more people
died from shootings in his state
than from covet 19. so today
first state in the nation is going to
declare a disaster
emergency on gun violence
governor andrew cuomo declaring a state
of emergency a move that will commit
more money to combating what he calls an
epidemic of gun violence
shootings in new york city are up 42
percent compared to last year
including brazen and random attacks in
times square and on sidewalks in broad
daylight
26 people were shot in two dozen
shootings this weekend alone
about 50 of our shootings are gang or
crew related right now
and we also have an increase in
retaliatory shootings so
one person or two people are shot and
then someone from that side is now
retaliating
the atf led fox news into their new york
city gun vault where
row after row of confiscated rifles and
handguns are stored from crime
scenes scattered citywide the atf and
nypd are working together to combat gun
violence
this is the whole city right now fox
news received an exclusive look
inside their new shared headquarters
where agents are using a new analytics
dashboard to seamlessly share intel
in real time about guns recovered from
crime scenes
shooting investigations and shooting
deaths it's an unprecedented effort to
get guns
used to commit crimes off the streets
while identifying gun traffickers
they hope this will be a model for
cities nationwide
we have to have a rapid tracing of
ballistics to make sure that we're
somebody who gets caught with a gun if
that gun was used in a prior shooting
they were able to rapidly connect it to
that prior crime scene
so we can hold those people accountable
when a firearm is recovered
we submitted for a tracing and we get
the results in a matter of
like a week to 10 days it used to be
much longer time span
the nypd made a record 2300 gun arrests
so far this year
that's a 39 percent increase compared to
last year
nypd commissioner dermot shea says
though the problem is that about 83
percent of those arrested on gun charges
are released back onto the streets he
blames in part
the city's bail reform law passed in
2019.
mike brian yena starting us off in times
square brian many thanks